D
26EMBEECR
O
SPECAUTHL ORRIEE WK SE OESN
C-
OUANSP OR BINER W MO
O
P C-SPAN
NOW.
>> NEXT,NGERETRI RUS
SIESON IN E.
RAUKINGR
PANETALKSTLIS UT AEDBOIL M
ANTIOG LISORSUCAL PPMICOT, ENOCD
ONNCSATIE D S ANTH
S GOAF
IARUSSNDERE PSIMILANT VDIR
TIPU
E TH CLANTATICOSNCILOU H
S
HOCO-LONURG ONERSANVTI
.
EL H,LOE,VERY EONND ACOEL
E
' TODAYNES'PAO  HOWL, TTERDE
RU
IA.SS
I
THEAMTO DIRECOFR  U THEAIKRNE
RAPROGMT  ARVHAARD UNIITRSY'
S
UKRAARN IARESETU ICHNSTI ATEND
M
DED TIGELHT COSBEO  A OFNSPOOR
THT ALEVE ENTH TG ONWI
HELANT
ATNCIL CICOU
WE''O D ANY
SPECOR ME N
O
ABOUT P'UTI'SOVES MO,  THE
CO HTIERSAONO AS TBE HOWP STO
U
ROSSIAM  UDIINVANGNEKRAI
AG
'DATOY'T EVS ENWILL OOC FUSISN I
THH  A RICNEL.PA
WE
ARILL  WSTWITHT EY A K
TE
HI
PHER,
R LMMAFIKEDAN TUTHO AR,VEHED
C
ESINCLUDIR RETEN. EDPH
EE -
BROVDLE,ME FORSOR UPD REA
UPRMFOER SIEMERE ALLD COMNDMAER
OF EUR AOP REPATIVSERENT
THE  FORNTCEEREGICTR SAT
INTENAL ATRNIOS, TUDSTIE
SETOR IR DECOF TASIA EHEURHENIOR
ER ACENTATLATHT E ICNTILOU CNC,
INDIA STFEHEGUISD M  FLLOWRO
A
ATNTICNC CILDRD , ANANIY
GOKDNYU,HAIRCETH OF E
R
FOE FER DENSESTESTRAGI.
E DITHON WUSSCSI MODL ILBE
Y
DAEL MINERRI H
URT MELE TOOTHE N FL
OVER.
>>NK THAS,RY EVE
I WOTHLED AVE ELY T REP
TI
ISHEINSTGUKER SPD EALL
OI
AFTEEASPK
MER .
ATWH AM  IO SALEAB TTFIY RSF
O
THAL ALISS THI T WAONER THE
GROUND ANDE BAN  OTHELLETTFI
E
W MOHSNT A
I W MOUNDYAYOU THRGH
RSLOMEKITE
IWHATEDITNE WSSON FEW A MTH
ISAGO TI SIT AUAON OF WAR A
CO
ALDND WARWAM R, WHI
ICHS
PR UNTABOBLYLE FNKHIABOPE EORUR
AMERAND
HE,RESO IN OSY  MANGHTIE CITS,
UE
WHH IS RATL WAEAR HE T B
F
HE T W
WE HERE ARELIND T I OOOFTEN
N
THET, WESISUT B IT  S AAD
ED
TERRIBTY RLEEALI
.
FII EDLM THAT, IA LOAV HE
FT
OME AGFR
HA TT.
ITN B HASEEN UT P IASMY LT
VIMO
LALEASE THE MES SUREAR
AI
AVE.LABL
NU
,  TMBERWOHEIN THOAS LT
US
DA ANDVE ENRS HOU, I REIVEECD
SUNTLCOESIS MOMVES SIFRSOMRA CDE
HEFROM TTA BATONLI.
ERTHES  IALING FEEF O A
THUNBLINKAE, HEISBUT  T WEAY WHA
INO VE TTHK.
DSRIMY FEN WHOTH O AREN E
OW TIELDHE
AR W.
THAND IT FEEEYL  A NOTS
POWHILITIBY H CAICN O
UN
OE MOTHREEMLESSR  REOTUTUR FE
.
EY A IT EEASTY REALI
H
PPULWOD HA T TENO BEE RUIN
E
RYVE,Y  VERURARNE FUT
E.
SPOKI NEWIE TH ORIEN FW
A E
URHOSGO A WHOOL TD ME ABO
RUO
HWHR ICRES  ISP TG ADININHE
CHTRENES,IN SAYOMATG TH SNGETHIO
ULDPE HAPRYN VE CLOSEN
I
A
AGICTRCE WAY, GBRATLEIN THEAN
Y VERSNIAROL THEOF CE OFLA
ETE THSOVINI UON,LA VMIDIR P
BEGD PHONEIN -- BEG FDN
OR
NNIVICAG AES.SAERRI
HIS SO T SIT TISHE WE TIUAON
EAR
I
NDIS[ILE]RNCEIB
IN AN E.ENMERGCY
WHHA WY DOE HEVD
WEUSBECAE  CAN OAN ENHCEURY?
ESALLI, TECAU BSEY HAHEVEEE B
N
THE  AESGRSIONNDIA IMPER
T
OF NHEEWA, RUSSIOL OR D
SS
RUIAYO AS UFE PRE
R.
THERNISE  A OLDIANUR EASAM DRE
PINUT,CH WHIAN IS
AL
EATTERNIV FRE DAM
THROME
OPEEUROANNE, U ANDS NEKRAI IIN
E TH ODDLEF
ITFITH IS E ETT TARSRG.
SORY COU ANTSHICH W IUR OLY,
,
WHIH
SOILSPLED OOUC MH BLDOR THE
OVALUESEUF ROPEHE AND TS VALUE
OF THE WEST, TE  WHAVEAL
R
OTYDU TE B AT SIT SID
I LIKEULWOD  THAO  TEDWET  HEAV
T--OHADD A TT WE MAV HE,EAY BMO
TAMPRE IORNTTHHA TN
RAL
, DUTYTIPOTHE LI TDUCAL TY
O.
SO
CAUSBEEF INEN TH IE  O WEEXTR
YSR O HOURSHE T AUSSI RAN
ENHAPP TEDO IMBADNVE
BAOM,
HEINOTE REMT OF PARUSSI RA A
OTECPRTSVERY EIN TACPLE A
E
YOUERWHE AVE HUS RSIANPE SS,AKER
RES IT IA RAANAL PDO'S BOX W
L
WIEDOP BE EN FOR ALL EOPE.UR
LLERE THWI BNE PLAINS I SPA,
ATWHBO AUM BUTELGI, SNDTZWIERLA,
EN PAR OTSFRICA AMEHE WRE YOU
K SPSPEAAND ISANH SO O
THKEN EEST HEAN-- C T WEST
HEPTACCE TTH O TIPF EININGE FR
D
O-THIS SOMLLEDCA CNMO
SENE
YSICH WHSARE WHEAKOU S YPE
N,RUSA
IS.
S IT ILETEA RRIBRE P
DECE.
, SONO HWEAVE TNL ORATHY E MO
L
TYDU,VE TE  WHAITIC PHEOLY
T
DTOO S
D IANANT W LASSAO Y,TORD, W
ITHATF YHEEEOU S TONUA SITTI
OM
BEVI RECENEI INNG THO LASHET
M
SOYANROALLS C FRIGOODM  F
N
ERE,THHERE T IS RYANL XIET
OUT THANAME ERICLY REP
.
UKEINVE RECEIT OFA D LO
OO
SRDROM  FA ANERAMICOMD
ROPEEU
E NETHSTERMIW NIRO FMNY,ER GMA
TIDPRESENEN BID,XP E
STNGDS WOR,HAUT B WTHT ARESSEDRO
OM
T?
THWHAT OCRERETEPO PRO
S
RE DETOFER
WHATF THE LECANDARS  SAYST'L'
ITMEET WTIMRH . PUNN IRY,AN JUA
TATHE WESNERAN TIGELOSTHAL S
UCH SO MOF TREDIIRHE C INLIBITY
NTRECEEA YRSFGIN,  A
STHN
UR OCOMECC, DANLS EWHREEWHE, AT
LL HN APPEIN?AI UKRNE
THEINTA?
-- IS THEIR CBILIDITYT? INTAC
INS  THIICPLDIOMATE, GAMO DY THE
HEHAVE T TBI ALITYRDBEO  HEAND A
KETAN SLY?IOERUS
AY FI PRHAORT, B IFAUECSE
PUNTIPENE HAPTOD NVAD ITHEALE L
ES ICITIINE,UKN RA IT LLWIA BE E
RY,DIER VY RTYAR W.
ISTH IWH IS ATHO TN  WUGHTHEI
S FRE THE AS ONEW MTH
AG
ACFISSNGS, IER A PRAY,
D
BEGAD MY TINIMISTRAHE AONND T
ANAMERICDM AIOISINTRATTON E
H
IMREE AL DF SIENON O
ETH
AGTREDY.
ANK YO MUCVEU RY
>>HANK T,OU BERFOR RDNA,
R
ROUOFND
KSEMAR.
ELREWE A DOUEDIGHT YE. H AREER
AN
RAOUAND E AROR THEND W
LOT
BEARD,RNN' WE CAITT'WA
TYOHECTLAN ATIOUNC CIL I
N
NUJA
Y.
WEILL W LARK FOOORWINTO SD EE
G
U YO
TINIM MEAHENTRE YOUE, AIGHT RTO
AYEE KP PRPEG INFOR E ACIN
UK
INRAE.
E NOW, WENVEHA A PTI TESNG--
E
ANVEHA A FANSTTAIC P A TELODAY
D
I AMASNGOI TO O THK EM T
VEGI
SHS
. PGEN.-ELIP HIB-
NEOVEEL BRDLOME, SENA ASLYST
C.INR DI VLAMINPUTIIL W
E
UKE,RAIN OSAERS THDIEE,GR OERSTH
TIINN SN'H'ISMADET  HIND M
P
ET. Y
N YOCAU GTH UUIDES TIH ROUGPU
'S
DEAKONCISI-M
GEDLBRN.  EEOVE: ATDYBO THA
YOTELLS UKN THEY PU WOWHAT
ISNK THIEG,IN TAKT  THATHWI AGR
ALN AIOF S
T.
MELET SEAK ME OBIONSRV B
OW
T HAWEEE. S
WETOAV HE EMBE REMIRR,ST, T
S
IISS CED.TRONIV
ITNUS  IMAEDFACT BFOTIY PUN R
PUA
ATWHS  IANIMPOT  IWHIS, ATS
ATTH
SEURPO?
WH TS AT IHE GG RYINTOROET FM
ATHA TS EDNIFEMAST
TSF
LER TOVHELET COASUP,F DA OYS
ANN
E GHT OUOFTECTGIN
THAIAGNST  SUNE ITEDTETAS TAK
I
S ONTHAT ME
HTIG B
OPRIAPINPRHISE,AT T IS NND
A
Y ON SWETAURFUR O T ANDK
WOR
UR ATHWI OIELLSATHE R
THR P
KEA FORLLIEUR O A
MRASIN PUT HHUE  MADA GE
NTSTINVEME,HAND A T AINT BRGS
FEO
THATE
IN
NTSTME.
HE ITOGOINS G ANT  WTO
EE
HEMANDDES S IAN MADE EVI BED LIE
ILLNU CONTITO UE SE
THS
E MENTMO HSHAUF MANANTUREACD
D
E HER ONWE T GNDRA-  - TONHE
R
NDOUNT UTS HILE GE
HO T.
DOI  HEL BIEVEINISE  TAKLOOKG
TATHEOS CT SRIPITE  -- TH
.
AVE WE HCARE BTOE T TOL FUNO
RD BREWAADAVIO BEH
EED WE NTOID P AVO THIYILANG
S
AM GKRTHE WI UANAINIHI CPS
HITHER O C
WETO H FCOUS OOCN
UT
OGREPRSSET AT  A SEA THEAT
INTABLE Y M HUMBLN.OPE INIO
NAAND FIY,LL WED  NEETOEM RBEEMH
LDS
TCWAHI ROR F THEF ULESTS O
BA.HABEVIOR
>> TOU,NKHA Y G.
ERENAL
ANEWDR, Y THE AOURE F
MEORR
NISTADMI OERFENSE DEFN IUK
E,RAINRE GVEO AT THAR YOU
PE
E.CTRSPEIV
IFNVIN PUT IAT, ADEE
KE W ANDISISHAT  H?GA ENDME
T
TFIGURETHAUT O
.
UL YHR RUNOU TELGH LOUIK
Y
ENSC
THDREWAN: FOK YOANU THER
ONVITAINTI
.
I THINK DINSTONRUCTALG L
ORBEHAVIND ARI SCENAOS,
DH
TTY  PISRECHMU 24/7 HER
I DT'O' THEY NKHI TLYTUACALN PLA
IKHE-- T LELY SWORICENAO ULD BE
VAIN
I EYK THINTH WAN TTO WESHET
T.THN
EYTAN TO WE TSTO
.
THTHINI K TH WANEYT OWESTE  T
K,N
A
TOIDVOAS INVANDIO ATHT E
EN
WA TD,HEY ES TNTHE WTOT AK M
E
A
STEAGRT JE W, ERTHEYEL ILAGRE
NOTOT NVADE  A--ND TN,S A
JUSTEAGRT R YOU -- AS AREAT G
STGEURE,HE TY WE AGILL RETONOT N
.VADE
THGEILEY WL T AHELL TCO
S SINCESONENAND D U UVIP GINGP
THNO
G.
TT NK THIHAEL A LISIK
Y
ENSC
TIELL HWIAVUGE HNCESIS RTA
E
IN UNEAI.
AVTHEY HT BRE OUGH
AINRD
RCFOESDY ALREA
.
EYTHGEAV HE HU
AP GS OF
TIPACABILI,ESE  WBOUTOWKN A
ATTH, AND RUSLLA SIWI B TOABE LE
NCE ADVAITQUENIFI SIG INNTCALY
THEASE  CULL- AOF F
ALSCE
IN
ONVASI.
WE DID RATT ECENSTCSISTI P
O
ANSO OT OWN SH ISTTA-- STI
S
LLPOANAT ON SOTH
SHOW
NSRAINUKIA WANT TOENEFDA AT
VERYLL SMAAGER PCENT
UKOUIAINNS WPP BLDE HAOY T
NDLIVE UUSSIERANUL RE.
ISOMET ANS, EE N VEIF H
TSGE
SOMI
T TOICFFULNE HMA IGIY
TE
ING E ARGOOLTODHEM  TN
DU
MINID ANADON.RASTTI
EY ATHREPE SGNDINLL2  $BITOION 4
LI BILON U.S. AR YEA TO
SUNEORT PPNOSTENXITESCONO EMI,
BUTIS IT LE NARYO IF CAU N
EX
E APTROLATTHATTH TO
E
TERRKRY OROF UNEAI.
AKE TOONORE  TWOIE CITDOS ES
NO
GIT VE HNY SIMTREGATIC
AD
ES,NTVAAGUT HERTS  STA
THA
ONS NCSATISISTD ANREND
EVERYTSO ENGHI, ALLYENSSTI
,
THERISE  NO FOR INPOT O
EMT
HAVE A SCA, MALLVOL F.ORCE
THAYLYE ON W TO MR ATTEIS IF
EYOREDTART FVAIVE  LIN
ST
OF C WHOHELENTRYOU
[I
IBISCENDRN
]
HATHRT OSOF LEDANT  T
BUE HEN, T WEAR AALKI TNGUT ABOA
RJOEUAR I WN OBPE, ROPR
THGGBIESTIN S W WCEORLD IARI.E
WWELDOUE HAVST A SUBTIANALEC
RIOMONIC CS SIFOR O ALL
F
EURONSMI, LLIOF OUG REF
D
OSON.
W THHOIAN RUE SSY WOONECOMDUL
B
WITH TLEO THATANSTD  FRO
E
WODRLOR S FG THRTTAINLD B WATOU
E. DVELT TFIIFCUINIMO AG
AICERTNLY, USNIKRAIAN
CAN
OMPRIARUISE SSONS TET R
K
Y  BMANYOD WGS ABANDEDOUND
IESOLDRSSA, THOUPRS ANNDD ABLYOA
SH VERY , T TIORMENDTHS
U
THNDS.SA
TH ISAT N T GOIOTNG
BE
O POLIWES
CABES E USIT ITFFDIICUL T
O
EXPLAT TN HETUARY E AC
IN
DOAIING  UKR
I
T TH WOFHAEY CANTHOUO  DWI
FLG
ION,NV IASCH W WHIET
STE THWEREAL TO LYSCAR BE
ED
ERAINLD WOUSSST BE RE
TE
D WORL TD WOULBEBONGALKI A
UE
POLNTIANV IN,ASIOO S
FOINIORMAD
WIRESSSTED,SE TTHA B WE
Y
VE
IMIT L.
D IAN T THINKYHELD A
L
TSSIBPOLELSOODE IN ORPTO RR EA
O
MEERS ANRATHHA TNAC FE
, IF CTUAEYTH ATEMPY LLATCEO
INA
KRDEAINE
>> THANK YDREW, OUAN
I WT ANTO P SOML ULONHOSEOFE  T
ADS THREOMEN AIN M I BT,UTT WAN
H
SANVCON
ATHEHER, HHEANOW C TT WESET
G
N TOEAVE WITHOUTNGEA APPSI
I
I ATK THINTHBITH IS E G
.TIQUESON
R:HEATHES, THANK.ELIN A
I' DO'C
.
KRTHE LIEMNER UNDANSTDSS  THI
S
AN E AADALE ORTEOMCCMODA
TESTRATH, GYAND EEST  WNLYRTCEAI
LLOWS ATTH APPACROH, TRO
T
DIALUR WUEOG OOUGH TAYHR T
I  NDOOT MIE BELVER.ILIN PUT WL
ATY EDISFI BHIOFANY  TDS AN
I
EE AGRANIT WH HOANDRE D
W T
CAHI TS.
E THLLS COSTWI BERE GHE FORAT T
E
HEPUBLISTHES OF TEXT IT SY
EN
T
ANESIDD ENPUT TINIDUS JT SA
DAYESTERISTHY ERE GO  NGOIN
BACK, SO I INTHKOW N
IT, S
TARSTTINGCUO TNFF O EVEA
I
TO YITRNG STEKETA AP
AC B.
ICALTRAG,LYHE B T
ADMI
TIONSTNIRAAS A HTO
EEG
LKTAAIN E  ONCAGT
THWIOU
INQUREIRGUS RSIA TWALLO PU AY
OMR.ORHE BDE
, EAAT LSTUR OTE
ENNTSI PREDENDDN HAY A
ENESPBID
ASN WADES  TKEHEA GENEV
SUS
I
ST PLEAB ANDLEDICTREAB
U,
ATULWOD THOR WK SAN, D HED AIWE
WLLWI KNOMON  ISIX HSNT.WE
KNO NW ON SINIX M
SSTHE RUNSIASCAL EHEY E,AT T
G
IALO DOTHIE,GU NNGHANG C
YHEILL  WWE SEHO LON
TA
CON MMODUT TE,AT BBLEM PHERO
THEYIS,  H NOWAVE A SETOAR S
HI
UBSOGH,  PYY,LICL MEA FRS I
HIS TO
HIOSORICST LS,HE AS OLD  TUS I
N
NE,JU30N TH OE ER ANNTHIV
F
E FATHLLE  OF THNIVISOET U
A
HETREALRDY SLYEGATICALT LOS
UKERA I20N 14,O  S IS THHI
S
TOTEATMPT ES RTOREHI TS.
ILL ISTH W DEF TBEHE
ININGFO
TOE
DESTADN MININDTIRAON A
UNDTHEYD THSTERAN TATHETAKE S
N
ENOR.MOUS
>>
OW HAN CIN PUT GW  -- ETHO
E
THT ES WT GETIPUN TO L
EATH
WIAST APOUPEGINIM? H
WH
OU AREAT YRS?HOUG THT
>>VEE ARY
NT ABE POIF ORNO  NRETU
TI
PU F
N.
BLTHE PUOFATICION SE THORA DFT
TITREAESAS BALICLYEM REDOV MT
UTINOF PS M''INGUVNEERM.
ROO
BYING  MAKPUBLOSTHE , ICHE
A
ALMO IDET STOSSI IMPRE BLFOS
U
TOIND  FIND MESO KOFAY T W
DEE AL-ESCATON A FS BAAIR SI
WOD ME HPUULE WOD
ACK
ESFOHIS RC.
REWE AHEIN SEEG EQU IS IT
INRIABT
TO.NA
HESA DOES YO  NAT THEASNU
ER-OMBNE BEYMAOGN,
THEIN
TRUSTMENTT HATHE MNAI
,
EDE THUNITTA STES,G S  IUSIN
TO
BOTHMI UNDERUT TNEHE PEGIMINE
OME AT HDANRIVE DEPIARUD SS
T
EAS T POATUSR WESTH
WHC
UTINREWE PEA MNS SPH A
E EF
INEUEFLNCND A ARE FEAND  H
TOMA
DOGHBO NTEEI
,SO IY GE JUD BN'PUT'S
TSEMSTATENRD YESAYET  ATH
BENIH
HAEVESLI TDOIF HT E T'ESN'
NOE  HE LL LWIOS
RAINUKE
VEFORE
OF UOURS CE,GERLYNDIN THI
IS
PUTIA'S FEND AECOGNI
AT
THF INE UKRAIOES SU
N
NGBECOMIE, S ATABLOURO PSPER
S
WESTNRA DEMOC,CYWILL ED A
POIGGDAERT THEDNT AT OFHEE AR
SSIA.
ETHOWER PS EXF  OITPLAME WILL
ER OSOONRATER LMINEND UER
PUI
ME.REN GI
FOR PUTIN, TS TAHE SKE
ARERV
SU.IVAL
THY S AT IWHAIHE SD TNO IHERES
OUGS
THNUA  IS MA CURFACTED
NEGERAL B PEDLOREVEUTNTEDOI O
.
WE CAVE  HTOTOTINUONE EV TRY,
N
WEARMI PESSIUTIC ASTBO
THWHO
ST
DNGRETHENE.ERETRENC
INI THDETHK E BISTADN MINITIRAOA
IXSES NT MLS SEDIGNA
.
RDNOTR SEAM 2 HN HO BASEE
S
WE  HINOWANDLVEHA HT, TEDHAEV
UGH  TENHO IITSUR M O
LEE TA
OR OGERA, NE OF IN
OF INPOTSGE.VELERA
AND IEE AF WEGRS TA TO LK
T
BAPUANY LLFCK OOP TROS,
L
BE STH ANOER WL IGNAOF TITNEO
G
USHEHERE W TWANTY S. U
TRAGA IC B
NGSREAMIDI
.
INK THISHERE T I GNIATERRE U
TY
W AIENGMO ALL
IRONTILYAL, PUNESS  ISUCC
B
INNANGRIING TOR,OG TETHES  AHE
DDI14 IN 20
HE MGAO  DIT A
ITHARD IS BELI TO E,EV 25 BUT
S AFYEARRTE THEATO- N
SSRUO
ACTDIUNNGREWE,  A STILL
I
--T THA IS RDOVE BELIE
TEARS YEAFTOTHE R NAUSSI-RA
UNE' ACTNG WTIR' S
LL
SECOG THINE NTMMS
WETOE NOADT NUEPLO DY
EAR
ONWEAPUBORS  SALANSTTITOM CBA
LORCESFO AA' RUSNGSIB'S ERRDS
THG''S G TOINL  BE AL
E
PUTIN'I'S GOATTOG  CREA E MUCHMO
TE TREHREAIRNGNI ENVORMEONNT F
I
HELMSF IFHRGOE ES THGHOU WIT
NDTHIS AHA TT'ERWHS Y THMAE Y
BESTILL  C S AMALLNCHAE OF
INCICONV TO  HNGIMACK LLPU BUH
.
BUT E HWEAV T OURPLO AY
ARK
LY.LFILUL
ASIT WAT SD  GOOTHYEBOMODEADL
DIDS AT IGNIU
ILSSPOIBUPOFITY  SINPORTG
I
ANURGENSNC
Y.
BE TEA RDYO S PUT IE SKOMINTHENA
S T LINOSTINRLY EAGOG AR. W
AK MAYIT MFFTHE E DINENCEER I
LYREN
GSTPOURIN ACT NNDOT AY USUAIN
G
FORC
T >> WHA YDOOUE MAK OFHE
ST
TEMATENT TH THAE
E ERAR
AN MERAMICY COITILARS INANMPIE
THEONBASS,ND T AE
Y HEAR
NG AINTHKIHEMIUTBO CAPONL CAWE
K
AT
DOTHAEA.E MN?
A CASFAR  I TELAN TL,
BRL TOTAFA
IOICATN.
CAYOU NEC EXPSSE T THRU
O
ANIFJUSTY  IANASIONVN ITBLAMD E
NSRAINUKIA
.
EY UILL  WBERYNG ESIVE
NTARGUM.
E USBRE THOLD MIENOK PROSE O
F
NATOY POUPSEDLDEMA
TO
ACGORB
WHBYH  THEAY WHEGO, RBAC
V
HIELMSFEDEF RUSFUTE-  -RE
E
YEARRAVEL
AGS O.
ATFABRINEAE G THIDET  THATH
S R
K AH TOMAW IILMISSESN UKRAINE.
T
S
NOT MUTTI PNGANSILEISS
H.
NEVEN INS RESPO RTO TE HESIANUS
IOVIOLAT TOF TN HEATY.RE
ITHATINSOMES THHOTHATG  SD BEUE
D.VI
HEBUT OKIL WL COP UHA WVETERMY
FAS THAND NSICBRATIOSE  HNEED
VITO CONOWE NCHIS  TPEN OPLE
ITT'S NOSSIA'FA
T IBU DONT T''ISK INTHL BE WIL
CONVERYG FONCVIIN
THR EIN
IONARNTEATLMUNI COMTY.
AR,ASSA YOUAIE  HAVPR
THMIN BIDEADONRANISTTIOR F
LIHANDRIHENG T CSISAP C.ABLY
WEHOCER, SVEINID TENUTIN-P
YO
UR CINL, PALUT
AS N HOT
AT-ESCDEALEDS HAMANDDES
VE
LY,  GROWNOOD ITAN LHE LIKKSE
E
UNITWITA STES OUTHT
ES.LACATING
IS BID BLOWING IT?
PP>> I AHEISRAED T INI
REONSPSE DURN HEWEE
G INH
CONFESPRS CEER TONKENBLY IN
HA
UKRWID TH FORNIAIANGNEI
MISTEREMN  ITHVEE  LOVNO,MBER
WEERWHE T D  LAIOUETHTHE RE
GSTHW
VAD,NI MEANGAJ MON SECORTI
,
LITO ARMRYS .KRAI UNE
PUAND H
EAS E
T.
ATELRTFOUNUGH, TY,HO WE
AE
SENGSI AENLOT IN TDEHA
IAITT
NGRO RE,POESNSINGAV WER AND
WEN  BNESSEEWIINDEALG TH
EMATOVN PROC.IONS
BUEDT I  TORSK  TALFITBO AUT
BERCYPL TO EX.N THAIIS
EMTHE KRNS
ONER CYBIN SCETHAY M, WI
Y
AN RFRPOESNSE  TOMHE
AD
TINIMISTRA
ON
E THER LREWE REDGEESIN IN
VANE
HL
LAIDDEBIN N  DTHOSR RECLE EA
LIIN PAIAGN ALLSNEHO C
IN JTIPUN Y,UL ANDINUTKE
O
INOSTHE ERTE SEPMB AERCTND OOB.
ATE  S THEAMWE WTIMEE KIRE LNG
O
, GRKINH WIT
IALUTN
EDTRODINUCU.Y TH BE BE ON N.CY
.
ARST FIOFLLINHE A TDMNTRATISIO
ER
IMSS TO ALRUWE WHOIAM PENT S
D
PUD LEN ARNE T CINYBERT HAHE
CO
BD ULPUSHUNENID AROWID TH
IMTY.PU
XPTHIS E DINLA THEEFEIFRENC
TWMAY BECRN EETHE  ONIS
UKRAS E'I' INRDBOER TING, SHEPR
THE AND  ON ISCRISE'RAUKINS
NOWRDBOER
INHE S T WE INPRG,IVELFEEFCT
Y
SHPU BUTED PIN
TOAVWEDAY  HT.E NOACK.
TH BOMIS CESHATOACK  WENS T HABE
N
SESPRR
RI
RT AFGHTE S THESPONG TRRESE,ON
E
O EGAN B TUTLK ATABOAL VIR ATU
A
H
PO WD OUTET,T  A GASIFTOIN PUT
.
E WE HAVITE THSUMMATAN, D WH
ENHAPP
S?
WE HUICOE NTINAN RNGUSSI
ATPROVOC.
IO
EDE THUNITS ISTA STENGAL TKI
OUT
A'LES ALKSVEHA TND A
RUSTH
TALK IIAS OUT G INABEPSTS
E TH PATAVTO WWAE Y S TARHI
.
ISTHEC E WASSPYIALLIC NEA
BE
YERYESTDAN  WYOED U HATH
NSSRUG
OUABTRA CCA PROZYVOONSTI OF
U.NT I CDUCIRONG
MICAHEL
APONWES IERO EANTSTE,UKRAN IN
LINKN
ABLKINTAG OWT ITOU HE WE AR
INGOS
NUJAARY.
IT IS LE BEE IKTHSUS  VARER
,DEERE KNND A W WOWHOINS  W
INS
THO.
NACERI
E CO HWEAVEYNVED WEAESKNS F
Y
RLY,GURELAIASP EECYBONLLY  C
.
TNEI EDNEKEO MA OOR MENT POI
'
DOT'INE  HK WEAVORHEREACD
ET
REOF NTU
I HAN'T OUNYVE A DHABT TT
CAPU
U
ON DIM AEF HEEELS F TEED N
TO
.
AGREE WITHY  ANDRIANO  T
A
CERT WEXN TENTHEH ITHEAT
R,
THATIN PUTPL IS R INAYG FOETHCO
ONS ESNCSIL GE WHEIL USFRT OM
R
BYNG.TEEANI
DON'I HAV'T NY A DOUT
TBTA
ERTHE W MANL ILBEES IPLY AC
EUHA TT WSUE L ILIS OFSIA GHNROE
EFRELI IF OUT PINNLYRABSNE O
OS
U
A
TBORDERNOARDSOW AA.ER ATHRE
ISTL
P
ANS NCTISAONWN.DO
SCMOOWAN CLA PY F
TORHA.
YSA IHEHI TNK T MREAY AO LSBE
O
E PMEEOPLSH IN WAHOGTINON W
AVWILL HEIM A SCTARIL REA
GATHE  S IMES TONGW HOSTRE ATHNE
RE A S FARR THONTRGEUSSIANA
A
EGOR CNYATATIOOFY  NLNA
PO
WUSSILEHI RMARCCAA N INH TO
E WIRAUKINUNIT ITHMPWI IY,T LLTA
KE HIT ATH, ATWNDRE
DE
BESCRID,ILITY.ARIL
IFEEIDEN B K HISPSSE PROMI
SC
SAHEONS,TI TWILLY MA TAKE
N
ECS,IC HOMITINND P AUT
UN TRSTADEND
WESIE A AVPOONTI OF S
.
S 'I'T ILSTL NO TO TOLATEUGHOH
E TO MAKTRVEA RY SD G ONSTANWNO
.
AVT BUWE HTOE TO SP TNGS HIHAVI
WITALKS OSCOTHW.
NKS T>>HA JOHLOA T,
N.
HER,HEATWO TEEKS WIT
GO A,
OKEDLOTHE IK LE
DEBINAD
RATINIMISTON HADN I DNGOI
ACPLDIOMNGUTY, PTIR ET TOGHEA
ONNCSATIS.ONAGPACKE
LLIKED KELI BERRID N ANPA
E
RESHUWO TMBP. U
LABL WEESTK O
LIAT BTHERRIAND N PAWERES  NOT
TW UTHUMO BSHE ANDP, T
WD
SAS.TALAT TINCONTABTHINN K T
RE W TIFHE AAS CNGHAE,WH
Y?
NK I>> THIF ONE THE OEAN HD TH
ADBIDEN TINIMISTRANE DONOES
TO BMEND COMED.
E WATHERT OFA S LOLTATON CSUNIO
,
THE AND AN CROEUPE MEENCOUIL
T
K PR WEE A VUCODEDRONGY ERST
EMENSTATT.
NATODU P HASROCEDERNGSTRO
ST
.ENATEMTS
I THI TNKVEARHEY E RY
NSS ENTIANOUNSD COCIATS TH
H
MEHIIS TS  SE SSAGOFGTTRENH
D
AN SY UNITON BIOANCTNSUT
YOSOARE U ABIGTELYLU R
HTYO
BEND TTOSE RHOHECALRI
TSATEMSTENS THAT,  I AERE WHWE
E
INTOPR HAVE
LEMSOB.
RFO 2 THEANEU7 ROPENI U
ON
MBMEITS,ER ADDNCNAIOL SAONTIS
RUAIAGNST UIIASS REQSRE
IMITUNANYD TH, ANL BE WATIL
LENGCHAL
T'LES ALSLEARBEO  CTHEHA TT
OF TYPEATINVADESTTIONSAG NC
SAW
THTALKARE E OUT G INAB
HE
UALLN  AEQVAY STATGIN
CTIMPAE  ON EUANROPECO E
NE
AT AENE  TIMWHPRRG ENEY
VERYIG HH, EXD ERBAACTEBYHI C
ELS
LAGH IHINFON.TI
ITY,EXS ACTLTH AS ADAME BASS
R
MENTNEOP EURITTAE KES SS CUE
N
AN MY RS FRPEESCT
OM
WAIN
ONGT.SO
HE WNNGTOAS WHITS
STN AR
AR,  CBELEUE IALDIOGS INT,ORMPTA
RTICULHEN LYAR WNS ANSTEIO
RE
GHHI.
E WE HTOANP  KEECH
ONEF
ATUNCOMMIC TOPION ENW.OSO MCO
T E
S
ODACCOMM TATHAREIS WT HE YOU
TATHEN SED TRTO A HEAR,
S AD
TINISTMIRAOC WASON F
IN
ETHIL BERALAT.S USSIA.- TKSAL,
N
DHE TTITHN E NAA-RVEUSSI
L,COUNCIU HE TN YOIDD HAPRES
R
MAONND A C NOWR NCHAELLO
SC ILZN GERSPEANYMA, O
NT
PUTIN, T ABOKIALNGS
TUTHI
DI.
OGALUE
WAN ONONESACR TTSO THEIICIFE R
ECOMONYIN DURG VHE TSEERY
NAYIC .
VEHOWEURR, OLENC PRIIPSRE AGO
EQTOING  RRA AUIRE TNTNSATIC
.
NOTRONLYT  STAG MIONLIRT SUPRYPO
K
BUIF WED  HOLLUESTHE VA, ESWE
ARE AVG INTO HTHTOE  DO ,IS
D E
ANCEAMI  CON  THRNAT
ALETRHORICYI ILYS SAIG TNGHE RHT
THING, B TUTHISBE
IL WL
PTEXIONAFFICY LLDIR ALT ULFO
27OUNT CESRI,  DTOOY PA VER
T
S'E'WE DOP HE'ONT O
VT
T.
TDOHA
K THI IN SHAYOU VETHEEN EWO
NEBBLISS.
EYUROTRE N STHERE WHE S.E U.
I
E LL COUS. TT ONHI
NK T>>HASH
IFRE'OUINUST  JJOWEG USIN,
IVR
ANE  WUSE DIARSC TNG HSIOW
OTSD
TEEIN RUS
A NOSIW.
L WWEOULDE OVYOUR Q.STUEIONS
GONDHE AAD AUT P I THOSEN THEQ&
A.
IF YN  ARE O YITTWTER, COUAN
HESEND TANTOM  US ID L  WIL
R
YON.UE QSTIO
GENELRA BVE, EDRELODENE THBI
NISTADMIONRA IS G ALKTAIN
I
AINI UNGKRURGE IANNSLLS NTWI
THAWI, LLTEGYSTT RAORK? W
>>LYTA CERINEVS,, YE S
OF
OURISAN PELTSDIAV HE  WSESCUSD,E
N KRHELP T UTOANAINIS
SECRIN
LESS.
D IANEL BT VE TIEHAISTA IMPORNT
AWWE SHAT TKI WORST AGANGINHE TM
RWHENNTSIUSA WEENT IO TH
DONDASNBS, A TERT HAMOTH
S
EVSSRUIA RTEOLDD WHRO AUNASAT
ING.PPHAEN
INK I THENTSSUINRGBE AIL WL
THIGOOD
KE TI LIAN UUSO E A WOREMBLL
RD
LLEDCA RESE.
TAISNC
LTE THBAICNS NAT H
AVEND
WOOGL ERFUPRRAMS OF
RE
CESTAN.
A ITHISS CE PLAT THAAT N
A
BEEAE TOBL RS  ACRCHOS
FELPAND E HEAIHE U TKRANS.NIHNI
TH SURAME HI KNOEYW  TOGH
O
IN HE TKNOWY  HDO TO
THE F ORCTFA ONG
NIGAZI
ANCESIRESTLL TND A A
V
SED ENBE UT RON CAGEP ANEDLL U
D
THAT
.
UL WE >>WOO LOVED TRAR YHEOU
TSO
THAT.
OVER E PAOROUST FR E FIV
SYEARAVWE,  HHEENE SE TM
UD
Y  VUP AERBLCAPAE
RM AY.
HITASD  ROO ATEELSELFIT W
L
THELD.FI
ATTHE HEY  TARNO PTOPARERED
R,
R HE T S
.
EAJUYOU  HSTAVEOK
E
THOFGHHIWAY UTEA DTH OF O
KUWAIT, OR TOESHE T LATTESAT BT
TBU WPPENT HAHAWHS ENOSEOU Y L
SUPEAIR YORRIITR YO OVE
UROOPS
TR
WENOT  CANIS AT LETHCE
Y RA
GAINATTH A
THTOEEEY ND NGAS BE KI UNDS, AWE
BD  NEETOEGSK AIN HOW
WE
RGERBETT OEIE ANIZTH
R AIDE
E.FENS
TH
EE  SAMDCOULSA BE IDUT ABO
R CS
OT TTHINR GSHEGIVEO  T
E
ASEON COL.TRAS
VEOU S YOLTL RECEN
IN E
ERST SLAEV DAYALS,E  WENTSE SOM
BEREA TMSO TEMEL HP TH
,
BECARATHE IS GNGZIAC ATTTHK AT
S
OI GNGN O
, TH NOW ONL HATAS
YS
INACROIEIFD  LAS TSSHE
TVERE
SEKS I WLEEOFIDNSE  U
NE BES EDTO AED.REDDSS
ARERTHE  TACE PLESOUWEHAT  CLD
IN GHE TSEZORAY NERE AAS,
OU
IARAR UKINRSOTN BRHE
AND
ERSIST
TOOUNK Y SUC MH.
REALLY INTMPOR PNT.OI
DRIY,
REOUR  YFOSTN MIIGNI
ER
OTGN FORINEI AFFTRS TAIHA
LES
FEESOW N.
O HE ALSUNIDSA AMMDIOITN AN
L MEDICARANMET OU
HELP.
ENDOES SSENGDI THE TEA WPONS
O
UTER DET PERORIN,  M
ELYOV
PRPUTIWITHERNO ATH
T FOETPREXATIOINR FL
N? I T
>>NKHI ANYISTA ASSOM
ER
STE THWEAR CLELYO PS HEL TR.DETH
E LANG THI INE WE ED
ATOPERETH WITH IVNARRE ATTHATE E
N'T'S OKT PE. PUTIN
S THAT INFI
ORBEI
.
NWENDD TOEE UTHSTANERD  THEAT
STWE WGENT, LYHIT, KR UAINE
PE
DS DHEEPENWON  OTHE DRLCO E.
ANS  INOT D SO ILATE
UNY
XIICWHH EISS STAND
SEUFLFFICI
D ONEP DENNFLOHE T IWE
H
FROMNEMOY HE TEST W.
RA OTHEYPEE N TE ITHALGLOBEC
OMICONOM CNDTYMUNI AHFO SO RT
.
COHESO T EPAC NOMICANTYBILI I
OFB
MB OFER I THENT
TIONL
SYNANCFIE  SEM ASTNDTON TO HA
AIP
THENINNCRE IASSO
THVASIINONF  OT E POTHIN
TS
TH TOFHEM KIINNGNA REASOY,BL
EY
THY WO TULTAUND DERSNDHA TT
U
ITLDA DI BE US
STSARO
VENTADWHURICH
ULCODPO
RUSSIINDEA,SI B AS AUECSEONSOAT
ART Y HEST TSILONG
AS
E EOOF PPLTHET ,  DAYNOGBEINAB
LDO LE THOUP O ANYCC
IEDTE
RRS Y,ITOR ATH ASOONS
L
BEIN LOSGLA PICS, HNEELTERSOPAN
DO ON S, UND T AHEATTED NIST
S
RTEL CANLE HREUS TP O
AC
THAT, THE WIE LL BNDNIDEAL A
SO ON.WH
HE AENLL TS IC PTURE TOFHE
DE
EROSTYED TIPQUMENTEDT HAKILL
OPPEBE WLEILL NGAP HPENI
EV, PEYDERAYN RULEOP IILLIASS W
IZE REALT DOATTH IT N'E'NY
A
E, ASENSY WI TNDHELLE
HAV
MS AOBPRLETE.
HOM
MS WOBPRLEHITDING FUN
PRITMSH M
EYON.LE
LEMSPRAND OBIT WHPO
STCALITIL
ITABILY.
EYTHANER UNDST.D TH
ISERTHE IOON A CSC
UNINRSDETANDHAT OFG  T
USWE JO NEEDT  TE KE SMAURINSI
TH
PPHAEN
>>TE ME ETINU UPT RRYO
ANAL
CHOUNGELE Y
.
EMYOU SEO TNK THIEHA TT TH
IAUKRAINS SIN DE IROSTNGER THAN
A LOTF  OONRCPEEPTIBYS AN
YSALTS.
IFWEUS RSIA E  TREO US
S R
FOD WIE RCAN A C OPEUTOF
P
,TICIESOWOULD WHOLDHA TT
WH
OURNALY A
>> O WURF COSE AOKE LOEDTT. THA
ANEYTH CT A  DO LOOFE.AM DAG
TCTO
IR
SON, OE ND S AOMSTIESCI AEL W
,
T GE S, IHOSE T AIOCTNS
I
OT CLLRESUE ATANY ORPPT TO
PU
ACTHOSE LLONTIS WIE MPL PEO
E
SEESIANTLLY --  STUD ANWE
PEP
S 'L'NS AINOPIO LOT- -
UNDOPPELEDSTERANIF THA TT
HEE
WATSL AN REA'THD ATKE AS LI
-SCAFULLLEAS INVIONEY, THE HAVNO
GTHINO  T.LOSE
AN
D EALSSENLYJOE , THMA
F
THEME LD WOU BATICPARTIPINING
ATER THECAN.Y
SO
OTT IS I NIO QUE ASTN
OF
TOTTINGEG , KRAI UNES 'ITT ANO
QUF TIONES OG,VANCADINT IS I
E
ESTIQUONWH OF NS HAPATPEFT AERTH
LL FEYORMAISESY TABLAH
CE
NTAIRTN CO TL ROOVERHE
ORTERRITY, HAC TOWHEY ALTULYCO
,RONTL ITOW AND HOPAN MY PE
E
THEYOSE  LTHEYTEAFR  THELA CIM
O
COEDLL IT?
F TH>> IAL IR EIGOUMILTOS H
ND LSTWE AKRAIVEEA U
SO
YED STDEROT CAATTH IT J'N'
IN
THTONA,'ONEY D' THAT VELD A
LO? RT,IGHT
>> WT' TELL,HA' THE
NT PO.
EYUMTOANT  HHETEILIA T. U.S
I
GHT. NOW
WANCHTO PT SYLYOGICOL
RODN
SO ON.
RAINUKE HSO AN ASABEGTELYLU LAL
F
D
LVTHEMSE
INUKRALEN IAPEOPY AJ MORITS  AWU
STSSEDIS DCUY I , READ
TOFEND
DEELVEHE TMS
IDSTERAN TTHA TYHEILL  W
BA
SU
IANTL.WH
ATO WE DTO LAV HE
THER
ISE  NO YWA WNE CA A
O
TE WSTOPESN ATRNIZIONEKRIN UAI
TD
WAANROS EUPECYOC DEMRACH WHI
NPUTIAN W
SOSS E TALENTILYTH ONLHEY G WEIN
ASTHEK ES W TIS NT OTBEO EA W
,
CASSWEAKE NETLS EX IACWHATY
'O
N' WIFE D'TEMON DRATE
ARFE,K  WE ASNER OUPARTO NRSOT T
TRDEMONSEAT
FEAR.
ITHAEDNE.>> THICH W WNGHIE
Y, IND ARI YOUHI TNK
MAKISO
OT O ANG LMPTIASF SU
LYSI AURNA
EN YOUAT TOO LK HE PITNGOLLI,
NAO
UNTHAND E TE SITEDTA
E SO
R E BLAMFO.THIS>>
ESHO C WAR
?
WSO
T?
OUOBVIYSLHE TYRETHNG TOIO
E
AGPROPDAAN.QU
T E ITA LOLLUSOFIO INSN
RU
CIIASSN SOQUY,ET NO
TIS
HAOUABT T
T.
E
FACTWEHA TT , FO SEERLEXA EMP,
COVEVENSTAN SIDUB
ALTILYDE
D THEACRSELARIPOE PUTY O
FTIN'
PUS'REGI
LD CTHEYOUNAE  HAVMAATGED
IORMINFOATN-W T BISE,UTHEY
'DID'T.
WE C ARENGCULAALTIUR ONOS
ON, AIIFNIE  PEOANPL
ASCD
RETOY D  DEFENATEVWHER THE
ARIOENS, ANDWEHE T ANS
YES.
E WHAT WM EDNE FRO IE THWEST
S
NOT TO DUSCOISUNT  TND A NOT
O
Y SATHAT IFAUS RSI STA
UKRA
OPPEE INSTSTINRED SIWE
T FOKETA INTED GRRA
.AT I
THTHENOS T  C
UKWILLINRAE FENDE  BDEGIN
LF.ITSE
LEUNSSUT PMP IS INCOTELYLECR
SH HAZY,E N'OUL'THART STT AT
AARSCENIOTLL. A>>
HIUT I B T HNKAVETO DE IV
T
TRIT IS S
E
DENDMS THEUTVES.EL B
INT
CELRAKR UNE,AI THERE A
E
Y TIPUN MAIN TBEHINKABG OUT
GOINNU, INTHE E ERMBS ARLOA T
E
R.
IFEERUTTI P,NG I ST AS TEEHA
AN ONITYORPPTU
>>HE AIST TGE OANDVTA
FKING
TA C OITY  OORNEION REG
D ANASTHENICIN TALLYRY
HO IHEOMT FR T UT  RESOFNEKRAITR
ETTOIED  G BACKE D , ANTHDWORL
P
LLNGPLYI ASE THETI SONS
H WHICSS DISWECU
THNA SCEEEO OFRI K CNG OPINE
OR SMANELLEGIOEN OR N,EV
A
RGEG RN,IO T
S ISHI A
ENARSCIORIHICH W B
S ALNGL
GATINEVE A PARTSQU CONNDSECEENS.
RYAND VEITEW F POS
SOCT AOWLLUAY, HBLNC IREDI
SOT DSUN, BU WE THONLYAY
NO HA T HOP AVENY
OESFI
HOLDIS, G INTHHE SHOKE AD ULTA
PARHUGEHE COFT  T.
NTOURY
BU IT THT ENUEST AIS Q HOWN IOOF
S GOHE IG INTOTHEE KP
UGE
OPARTUNE F THCO
WEEDTAAVE LKHEUT ABO TY. H
IOBIL ON
THECSUB REPLI.
HERE WHISTOGOINE G PE FIND
A
TOADUALLCTY  ANISTMIERLLT? THA
THE
BICAPA
TIESLI?
ADISNCVAING ROOT N A P
ER
HIM.
ST CHEAN EIRLIABSH A
ORRIITY.SUPE
TBYHE T WAYAVTIACCAL NDTIIAON A
, AIRSE AEF DEN NAV TNDHE
AE
RY WKEA A INSINGASTIES.GEURNC
LL OSO AE MATHF ESVANTR JOAD
LITIPACABIY AC TESHEALTULY
E ARVERYIFEA WK BLLI APPCA
E.
AL
SSEIS L HOSCOMIS NGP TO U
UN
.ARABBELE
S THAT IY WEWHVE BELA
AFO, ITSUR RE, KE IS LI
- -
EIGHHE
N IMEHI TS GARSP
O TWCA
CHINPRAPOAANOTONG E  EACR HEIN
H
HEM OF TPIHONGHAT  T WIL ONONE
B
TU NO AUECSENTSE ONWA T
O.
SOG THTHY INWHAT IATS E H
S I
PWET
BEILST WL ANKE WEAR
ART
TINEGOG.ATIN>>
OUNK THA Y,MU SO CH G
A.
>> LYIET MEL
CKD BA.
>>NK THA Y
WH FERMA GNYOZINGIZ T
A
TOTOWE SELL ONSAPRA TO UK
AN A THEISRERO WAYNY A
D
UNG'N
NO?
>> IOU WLDSTAY S FIRF O, ALL
T
IS U TTUORNATEANT HAGERM
Y
GEPUG INA REFTITAON O
CTRESTRIORG INSUPPRAFOT R UK
A
ATENIM TE WHESHE T WS NET EDTO
TED  UBENIOWIND ANSH IT THG AT
S
NG BANSTDIINE.UKY RA
GLPHEINSE T RAIHETS COS T
TU
IASSNSOT NROUGY  ONLTH
H
SA BONNCTIS,NK TUT IHI
GE CWIANS LLOME AHOD ROUNI PEERM
NRED STAMBU, TLS
A
O LI
MITARYPO SUP
ATHISSEUAL CTCAS HAT  THA
BA
INHE T MEWS  NIS ABE NAYOT
EA DLS  A HASIT BRAN POEERT
A
BENLE ITUS ONSPERTY AIO T SOME
C
SPPOICIF WEATH TNSHAT
E
RAUKAVIAINNS HRYBEE EN TG INTOGE
HEFRT OM TAT NEIV S-POUPRT -
TONART AUP SPOCURE PNDRO
CY.AGEN
WHERE E ERTHIS AREMEEQ RUI
L
ONSEEDLI C
USNS.
ERTHEE TW WEROEN MOMEN TS ITH
DEE
ONTIE  SOMANNE-DRO WLE RIFS,
LUNSODSEFA IKE USULAB CAPYILITI
THHOVEN W NSSSE RUIA
, E G USINTHNMOFUSE  UDANNEAREAB
ES.
THEYTH HELD REIUN GRO
D NY
DE AG SOINMEERI-SNNTIP
S.SYSTEM
T BUSTMOEL DTOERIEIVS
RA
UKARE INBI ATELARAL,
POTE
HOHE TY UILAIKRNE WL
LLUSDIIODNEE. HER
ANIT CO  GTOPE SLIFICIC AL AESNO
Y GEFUPELLMETHT E SA
CATIESBIPALIBE WMA, Y  THEHOITUT
SPESAMEFAVO OEDR
BLRAE
ING,NAFINC T BHEY ILLN CAST
THEMGET
BY GNYER NEEHINKTOD  T
BT
WHATOF SIN KD  INAIGLS
T ISND
SEINGN.PU TO TI
SISTH IIC P HAT
IECAHAS RRROERD OV FEM TH
MERKER GOVENTNM
,
TBUCO OF F SE OURLAASHOLZSC W
M
THELLFUY RE GENSSE, WHO HOPE
EM
MOTO BE RELI HARD-TH WNEHEN
E
ORSUPPAINGTI UKRAR MNEILIT
WING BRI CBO AUT A
NGHN
POCY
>>DOASR, YE SA HOUAV
I
OST LENG MANT POIMRTTO
REGATCWAH HOW INRDG
PLAYIOATN ISOUS T UTOW H PU
I
DES EWBIN.
RUTAS PINIDCTESPE B
' D>> IONOWT'KN OTH WHEERTR NO
HEPE RES
HICTS M.
TIELSFE T
GH HHRIS
BECYATPRR OVOCT N,IO THADEBIN
ULCOLLBED  CHAD GEEND AN
BUD S ONCOULBEUS PWID HEAND T
L
NOT NSARIECLY.ES RPOND
THVE IATS A RO DRYANGE
US
CONCONSI.
ETHING AN HDL CRI TOFHE
S K
'INRAE'R OVWAS TEHEERAST P
OR FOUREEKSVEFI WTUNANF UOR
T
S TOBURITEOPINHA TT NIO
SAYNDTI MEN H TONEDHEOFINANDLG
YO
UAD HAK JANLLE SUIV
IN G
PE RS RHAPIFAUSSI G
S INO
NRAINUKE,AMD STORRE WIL 2L
D
US
.
WED  NEECL SENTOD ALR SIEAGN
S
ATTRWILLE  SE GLY ONUSL OFAL
U
RUR ONEMI, NUS YSSCEARIL
AMICERAN, TOPROSRU MTOAKE
IASS
P
ATTHE OU CLD BANCHGED O,RNVEIGHT
N TH WHEE HOWHE IT
US
ALIZRET IF TESHAHE TYONTI C
TN
MAKESSICOE NC EONVEN
THE, ESTORE KEY, MLINTHL WIL
O
OWCKT BA DEYD N ANTHL WIL
COO UENTIN T IATTHREENTODEN ORR
S
>>
OUNK THA Y,AS AMBR.SADO
WE
OTE  HAVANHER Q
IOUEST.
RYLLI WI TTOGE TO T  AS MA ANY
S
LEPO.
CIF YOUUTLD UOUNMAND E
ADCA WIL IL U ON LLYO
KLQUIC
Y.
CH OGORDL ONLLTHE F WA
J --T
D AS W SAIY STYEERDA
ATF
NVSSRUIA IESAD THE UWI.,.S WE
L
PRLIIDOVE MISURYTA TO
OO
ABRAUKINE BEE OVAND
NDYE
PARRCUENT ATAGCKE THREADS  IALY
W
TLDHE.S.  UE THOVPRID
ATDW
ADILITALON MPPORY ARSU
?AN
SPEWHD ATLLY FICICA ITOUSHLD
R
IN TIDOVE ITED LHEIMTHATIM TE
A
VAILBEY  AORLEAB F
RAO NSINIA TE GRINTEATNIT IEUTH
ESFOEIR RC?
E TH YR FLOOIS.OURS
>>ES. YWE
PRHOUL SD OVS  THING
THOSAN A CLMATIMMET DIYELSE UTH.
E  T THIWAS, ANGS
S
NTMENEDIOEF BYE, TORHE DHAVEO SO
IL CMEAPABIESIT
N  IAIR
FEDENSE,T UT B WHA'EYTH DON'HA
E  IVES THILABITY TOH ASIT
DI TARERSCN,DT GEAN AENSSEIGSSNE
ONAPS.TH
EERTH IINGSULD E  WCO
E
M WI TLPHETHT?
THA
NY B K>>ENMOE REPE SC.CIFI>>
NOIL I WL ET US WNSEAPO N.AMES
TOEEWE ND OPEV DELILAP A CAB
FOCH WTHEMHISE IS A
ESF
GSTHINHA TTHBRINT G E TO EMTH
Y D
>> SATDY, ANHEN,R, JHEOHY,ND ARI
S
>>. YES
INDEALGH WITLP.S U. HE15RO FM 20
IDERCONSHA TT LCS TISOGTIN
A
ETREXEMIME.ON LGT
PLANSO, NGNIDO T TO AFTENGHIS
R
THE ON OVAINSIR THAFR TEE
INRT SSIONTAT S, IISOS ALMT
EVS  GABLYETUSO  INTA
TU WTHION ATOSLLE WI LE
HSMONTY,ROBA PBLOR F
I.
SO YOU, ITES WLDSE MAKE
NT
GT DOARINW  IT NO ORDINER
O
EATECRHI TRSS TAATING NDTH
OE
CAPARETILIES AINNC IREAS AG,ND
S
WREARE E MO REDYEA, TH
SADINREES ISIINCRS EA
REISINADESS HE TT DE BEST
N
WAY AINNY
LUTEABSOWOUL ILYT  SENMAD KE
SE
TORT STA SOOOSSIASN  P
>>
THA SO YNKOU M
NGEN SDIPO WEANSOUOW N WLD
SOA EN SD IGNGSTRO STONAL
PU
TINT  THANIT IER A SUT AIOUSBO
T
IPINGT.
D HOIT SULONBE DEOW N.
TOUNK Y,OHN. J
IN T 2014,IN KREHEMLOEEMS S T
D''
LL IRESIO STN THE N DO
SO
.
OUDO YHEHI TNK TMLIN KHT MIG
BESTILL HAOI DNG T
>>, YESDEREY HEUNED
IMSTT
OPPELENTO  ISATHNDOUR  F
G
GEORTHE AN RIOEVOLN.
IDEYTH DTN
OFNI DIGTHANTY, D TIDEY D I
TRI.
EYTHD EALIYRZEHET
AD
STEDJU.
WE SELIE BVEY CE TINHE
INF UTESIT OOURGE LAGR OFPSAST
MILIFAESKI WORRA INGN UK
Y EVERY Y,DA THEOUSHLDUN
TRSDETANDRET HAAND IZALEHA T
T
WHATNDY HEDO UTEESERTIMA
W
HO WKEAEGHE TIR RY ARUL ARM
D TH, BEANA IATS K BE RIS
U
O NOEYTH D ANHAT VE
T EINDPEENEMOCERTH DORTIRAC
OVERHEOTR OVERGHSIT
T
ARMEES.FOD RC
THMEDE ERARISCE FORS SE C ALOD
PSECH WHI DOR REPTS
TY
DERETO PSINTUT PINAN, EYD THDO
HAN'T NDNYVE A I
DEEPET
T.SIOVERGH
AT THANG CES
HE
TIOVERESIRTE TMAHEITAPAB CIL
Y.
BECHUSE CAEA LMIEL OEVF RY
LE
ONRTINPOG  TLYO PINUT
S I
UPUAU
AISTRS.
UAUSLLYIS THAT SH C AOLD EROW.
ADTHEY H 2HA TT INY4 01WENDD SAI
TROONDPS HADSES
WN
EYTHTR SENT PS AOOND HADOADS
SES. LOFOS
E RET BUTHONASATS THHEY
BEATSTVEREIMILAPED CABS.ITIE
>>
OUNK THA Y.
,TIQUESON IS IRCLNOT EA FOR
TH
ADBIDEE N TINISTMIRA
TT
TIPLEMIMENAG THINGS  WEMENRET
L
BKILLENH CUOTRRE UKRAT IN
ANS
IT FURE?UT
IF
LET IS I C W, THARENE IS HYTH
E
MINSKAN M NA TREVEN
I  FEVLIE TOAICEOR UKR TNEO
IM
THEMPLENT ESK MINMAS TH IE
N
DTIVOBJEM CTE OF P
INUTH
YOUR IATS NSE ES RPOTO
H>
ERST U INDED ANTHCEON
T THINI THK STMIE ADNIONRATIRNIS
TOIN TRYG A AR SQUE LECIRC
HE
ISHARE TT ES N NOTECLYSARI
EA
UAO SY TSQ.RE
FATHE E F CT OTHERMA I
THE
KMINSRA FRARKMEWO, HATHERN
E
OIS THES Y BANLSIE TEL, SENSE
NE TATIOTINST WEHAE. HAVO
ERANDI
YTRTO, ATUSH  PTHSIO ON TE
DEO
U LL LEOSEH VLEICS
HA TTT
TL ILKEEPEA EHEUROP
UNN
N ITUNED O.CTSEIONS
HISO I TDM TNKHE AIOISINTRAT
N
HAS EAAK ME CLT TH TRHANSE K
AMEWFRKORAT T-  -THHE MS
SI
ETHWORA FME WTHRK, AT AJEE RECT
O
NSMIN
BE FTI PUTNG
RDORWA.HAVN
UL SWEHODHETOREES TIE OD
'-
EDOCCUPI DBASSON,O T T
E
UKRAREN IASOVENTIGY.
IT
HAAY M BE O DORDT. THA
ASSSRUIA H ALO BCKED
RNYL
OGRESSN  ITHEERY  V
RSFITI
E OFATGNURINSKHE T M
ENT.REAGEM
IF PBUT S COINUT ICENVD TH
A
ITO MAMETI T AKEEA DL,
THIN
KRE THES  W AREAYARFORWD
REOF
HANSK,MI TTHAVOIT D EHEPS TRA T
R
E-DEDER INTNSATPRETIO.
QN STIOTOND A
TIN CASHEE OFAN RUS ASIY.
ONINVASE
LLAIHENIAL GENANER
F
HOG BIIS D THE
GEANR OF
ABORCOAT RN IOWITHSISIUSA INDE
ATIOHE T SENLESTR AFF
>>HA TNE OIST OFEW THF E
H
H ICWE HAVVEE RY LITETL
U
MATIESR TISONGAIN AICH , WH
Y
CTIVUB SJE
MOSTSETH OF E DE LNIOREA
F
HE TILALENER MYITAR
ANCOMMEEVED HA BEDPLN REACR OVEH
OULASTE  C YPLEA
RS
ALESPECIEW THELY N
D.COMMANEFIN-I
SE  SOMENRY TVEAL
TE
ADLEE.S THERER
OUSO I WT N'LDOSLA
BEINY ANRISKTS WHAVEOER.
OB
POUVISLY,EPLEOE ARPL PEO
E,
AND GSIN HAPUT FN,PE BMRO J
F
THEMINILG  A UANDIERNDST
WH, TH AEYREEE ERAR
OMO
ERAL GMEENS WITADALH RE
TL BDEEPATLDEFIENCER EXPIEHOE, A
TOEEVE BN IO ACTNCAHY PSI
.
ROSO FRSHA TT PE ICTPEIVE,
INTHE UKRAK IN S QUIISTEONG.TR
VEG STRRYONY.CTUA ALL
QU>THUPER SY
ORTIONES FD OHN  JAN
NEL
E.EEDLBROV
N HOW CAACKBLAT SEE NS
CON BURITE IG TEDERRIN
N
ONGRAGESSIUTND A DIL
G INE
NGRGBAAINIAIHI CPS LINBYD  PUT?
HNJOGO,  ASTADHE FIR
.
>> T IHINKHA TT AREHE TRE
AY
COS ARTRUNIEHENDOU T BCKLA T
NDRS THETO PEE ND CK
A
E,RAUKIN, RG GEOIATO ARES LSEIA
, T
EYTURK.
OUIT WA LD BWEOMELCTE S
P.
ASINLEG SS, ASSET
EFEE
SETSMA,  ME EVYBENINSILEISS
M
UKE,INUG ALTHOOUTHH AT WRA
LD
REQU CCLE OSERTISIONDERATON A
TH I PISOINTWOTIN ME,
DE
ETH R BLASIUSAN FLE SCKEA
ET
USPAE.
HEROTTEPS SE TAAN C B
N KEE
LL
ARTHERE ATUNDEE RWERS RO DNE--
LYTUACAL, I AG TALKM INYYONDBE M
E.RTEXPEIS
PH
>>RE THEEV ARE SNGAL TERHIS
T
DULD COBE IE, AONNDTEIS ST OF
R
E TIONESSP OF
SHTHE  TT-TEORRMTHHIATOULD C
E
TONE  DISSOBRINO G
VY
CAPHISSOTITAD COTEASEDEFEL NS
ME
LILLRAY, C YOU CONOUTR TOLHE
N
NDANTRCE ATS EXI STOPOEVL
FROM TOMHE RASIAANN COINTLE
U
YO TO.NTWAED
WE NAND DEE TO BE AS HE TN,
ESMOREH ISA  ITE
EDMMIA
TYBICAPALI, T HBONK AUTOOW D
WE
T WANASNC IRE
ATED NO
ATICPARTIPHEINION  TCK BLA SEE?
D
GO
.
TW HOWO, I DO WETHREASNCE
E
PAF TIESLI OTIOSE THNA
OA
BER E THUSEIPAVAL NACAESBI
ARIMIRLYFA LH ED WITITETH
PTEXCEURN IOOF TCHY,KE WHIEN TDO
SEEE KP ITIN DLFOWN  T
EST UTSOHW OF RNCOERACKE THBL
E SESOTOS  ANOT TOOM CE IN
CTCONFLIEIT WH THUSSI R
S.AN
>>.
HANK>> TO MUOU Y S
HEHEATR, DHAVEYOO U RNS ON CCE
COKING LBEOOT AWO-P A T
WIWAR AUSTH RSINV IRAG ADINUKINE
D ANTTA CHINHIINGN.AIWA
MA
A NOYBE T T FRTWO-ON
WEREME
IMY,DIAT BUT CLDNA CHIOU
LINDLG
TT, WGHEN
NUTS?
YOAT DWHO ABTHINU K TOUT THA- -
T
?
YOATWH DO ABTHU INK TOUT? THA
>> IOWHI TNK HHE T WES
MONSDE TO ATTRESROPER OUEU
AN
COLL ANDGUEAESOW H TYHE A
H
IAN RUE SSNGEALCHLE A
ENS
MESSEACLR TOAG ALLOUR OF
ES, ALLIULARRTPAICTHE ILYN
DO-PIN.
IFACIC
W  KWENOT IDPRESEN TN PUTIAT
PONG GT ISOI TOEN ATTD
THE
INBEIJGLY OS.MPIC
FOOFOSR THE  YOUHO WYOAL RECL UR
STYNT INDTHOUO SA EHTIGIN
,
NS
ANDNC FREESIDH ENTHESCI OF
E
AE.U.E  ALLT THE.MESA TIM
ITISAS W A HMORITOCAL NTME.
NOTBUT A O  TPURGHLITE
ON
UT TT, I BN SHEIG OF RUS
COATIOABLLORD STWON ULTHETCREH
MILU.S. CARITYITIEABAPIL
HOUEY WLDAVEO  THO AMAKE CS.
E
TWBENGHAEEN VIONRE TO SP AD TO
E ALLECHN' NATONO'STER
N
ANNGD HAANVIINO CO TNT TOUE
R ESS PRFO CSURIENNGOFLINGEIS
MMARATIOICN  IE N ETH
UTHSOHI C SNAEA A
ND
INDOIC.AC
URKIMANG SEISAI TWAN D.EF DENDE
KI THINS  THIAB MISORE
TW
WETHE IN ISTS GOG DD A
SPNFS REOF I
ENLUCE.HE
ETWHRHE I DO WIT LLIT WITYH ITUN
STREAND ND CTHNG A, ORRAOUGE
TERELAMODACC AOMNTTEIL
HS
GER  L AAR?
ISCRIS
S THATTH I.
KEEY
CONTBUT NGIN TO OKLO T
O XI
INJIG IMVLAND ADIRIN PUT,
LKINMOOUG ABT DICORE, ORNGNATI
INTHE T GS ATHEDUNIT
T S,LACE IIS AP
OWGS  AWE ANTANI-ERNST
AP
OACHPR.
HWEEEE TOAV KPHI TDINS  MIN
UCVERY MCOASH  WE UE TNTO
THSTRENGEN OURLERI PNCIPANS DIN
NARNTEATIOL. LAW
NK>> THAOU Y,TH HEA
NE
GELRA BLOREVE, E
E ARTH
H DRRKTUIS CONESON AT
NGTIN
TUNTEN  ICONGRI
N?PUTI
>>EL 'ETL, L'SK T NOTALBOT
APE ONWEA BUON, T GOOD
RO E
TYBICAPALIT THAWR IS PEDAPO INT
'T
O STEMSY SY AT TTHHEG N BRCAINTO
C
D BIIAN SSMOS FORLECE
INVANE UNGKRAIOR THEHIRD
TI
W, METHATA LDOU BE ODGO
THING.
>>UL FAB
AMISADSSOR, T  ISSPOIBLE THE
TARYMILIUP IUI BLDVER A S CO
RFO
CV
COULICWHH ISIOBED  VANN GE
HROTHUGERNA INTLTERF SUB
EK
INRAE?
UTOUIF Y PPRUG ENOH NREESSU O
YND
CI SGIVEPES OWAL PERHETO T DNR,
EN THIISS OUO T S
PLRA
UKSOINCI
CODTHHIS  TEIERE GAMCO --
S
THE  BTHE G
>>HEHI TNK T IUI BLDUP
S
DESIOD TEDO PRCONCUCESONSIS
R
R EOMITHEKR UAINEE UN, TH
ATESSTE , GERMHE FS,AN T
.
WHATAVEOU Y H DIBESED BEIG MHT
HIGVERYHE KONH  TMLREINH, WISTH
NK TAT IHIIGIS IT  H
HLYUN
LIHA TKELYO .PPEN
LD CTHEYOUDU PROCE SLL
SSFIUKES IURN SOINIARAN ETY.CIBU
AS YT OU KNOW,GE A LAR
TYNS AIE
TEPARPREDOEN DEFDIR THE
IGSOVERI
TE
LITRRORIANT I
RIEGTY.
ISTHAM GEIL W VNOL T GO
.
TIPUA'N'S  IESGRSIONEUKN RAIN
BAGOING 14 TCKO 20E AS H MAD
I
THF THFAER OUKRRCUENT INRAIAN
N
NA
ISALM.
>>NK THA.
YOU
LNEGERA BRE, ANLOEDVE
HEOTRU
, TIESON BID TWHENHE
ADONRANISTTIS SAYERO  NAMICAN
TRTHPS OE N NDGROU I
,
T  TDOESHALU IALSONCS O DE NB2OR
'?
C>> ISPANEAKTH TO
E
ESTENBO AHE WHAUTT  M,
EA
ALT BUACTU, LYNOTS BOON  OTHE
ND CGROUANACEDMPCOLISHY  BA
O
OFT  A
POIRWER.
ITE T
ATTH.>> WIAVUS JT LE
THSOK ANYOU UC MH.
UNATFOUNRTEY,EL WRE AT AE.
M
E  HWEAVUDE ONTO CCLBY
DAT
NGANTHKITI D OURIS
SHNGUD
PANETH
SOYOANK U Y VERUC MH.
O HE T VE M ARONANIOACATN D
EY DD GREETONYISO TH A
W
YOARES.ER HOE
D WOI ULTH TLIKE
BEI HEARD-NR HVY FLEORNRN
IS
LCGINAR REM, ANKSD W I
OO
AL TIKE  LTONK THAHEVA HAR
NTNDND F AOU FIONATG MAKORIN
I
E.
IS SS JECTUB IG T GONOIN
W
L WE WIL I DBEOINGT AGAIN ONJA
ARNUY 6.
YO WWEISH HAU PPYAY HOLIDS
AN, D WEIS WH UKREACENEAI P
RITYOSPR